well Russian airstrikes have reportedly
struck important infrastructure in
Ukraine's capital and there are warnings
of more to come in the South the
governor of mikolayev says 17 Russian
bombers have taken to the skies and
could strike later on Saturday for an
update on this let's bring in Natasha
Butler she's joining us from Keith
Natasha what are you seeing and hearing
well it was around 9 30 local time here
in Kiev when we heard very distinctly at
least four explosions in the city now
those explosions were not preceded by
Air Raid Sirens but those sirens were
very quickly triggered afterwards a
message went out rapidly after from the
mayor of Kiev that people should make
their way to shelters now that uh alert
has now ended and we're starting to know
a little bit more about what has
happened according to officials here in
the capital they say some critical
infrastructure was hit so we're talking
about things probably like power or
electricity facilities the sort of
facilities that have been repeatedly
targeted by Russian strikes over the
past few months in order to make things
a lot harder for ukrainians we also know
that some 18 homes were damaged in and
around the capital but there's a much
wider picture it seems that there were
also strikes in several parts of the
country in the northern districts of
China Kiev and Sumi in the east of
khakive and also in the South Southeast
support
So a much wider picture for these
strikes according to an Air Force
spokesperson he said that he believed
that some of these strikes were the
result of ballistic missiles we still
don't know exactly whether that's the
case for all of them but those are at
least his words of course will get
updates no doubt during the day we don't
think there are any casualties we've not
heard of any none have been reported so
of course that's at least some good news
in what is otherwise a difficult day for
many people across Ukraine all right
thank you so much Natasha Butler
reporting from Kiev